Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Alright, Drew, thanks for coming on.
I appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah, so you are the director for the EMS Institute.
Is that what you guys call it?
Yeah, so it's called the Emergency Medical Services Institute at Santa Fe Community College.
Right on.
So that's the official mouthful.
And you are a medic as well, correct?
Yes.
Yep.
Awesome.
And how did you end up in this role?
So I started here as an adjunct just coming and helping teaching the paramedic class.
I initially came in and did a little POCUS demonstration with the current faculty that
was here.
And the program was about to lose their program director who was moving on to another position.
And he had asked me if I was interested in stepping into this role.
So that's really how I got here.
So I went from adjunct to program director and then also teaching the paramedic program.
So that really started that journey.
But before that, I worked as a flight paramedic here in New Mexico and various other places
around the country.
And you also did some education or some training as a community paramedic as well, correct?
Yeah.
So I don't work as a community paramedic, but I did a program in Colorado called the
it's advanced paramedic practitioner program.
And it's a bachelor's degree that paramedics who are already licensed can go through.
And Colorado developed this program and after passing some legislation.
So there's several different colleges that offer this bachelor's degree.
And it trains paramedics who are interested in different specialty roles.
So it goes over a lot of more in-depth pathophysiology.
There's a semester of critical care.
Then you do multiple semesters of community paramedic, more primary care assessment, a
lot of behavioral health courses.
And then you do some specific community paramedic kind of prep test prep courses towards the
end.
So it gives you kind of a well-rounded education in different aspects of paramedic.
And then additionally, you can take like specialty classes.
So I did some classes in education to kind of help me in my role.
Right on.
And then is there much of a space as far as like employment in that area at the moment
or how does that?
So it's kind of a weird, I was having discussions with the Dean during the program, like really
what the role of it, what the why title it advanced paramedic practitioner and really
what that means.
And so Colorado has what's called a license paramedic and that's different than like a
certified paramedic.
And to get to be licensed as a paramedic, you need to have a bachelor's degree.
And this bachelor's degree was to make you a licensed paramedic.
And my understanding is that it's sort of like the standard or some kind of standard
to become a licensed paramedic in the state and that a licensed paramedic can work in
sort of any Dora regulated healthcare facility.
I don't know the legislation exactly.
So it's a little bit confusing, but I think it was intentionally titled that way to kind
of show maybe a trajectory towards the future of like maybe what the state wants to create
with paramedicine.
But it is not like a nurse practitioner program where you get an NPI number and you can prescribe
medications or anything like that.
So it's definitely not like that.
Yeah.
And is there anything like that at the moment in New Mexico?
No.
So New Mexico is different.
We do have critical care paramedics and community paramedics and all of those specialties.
But right now there is no like advanced practice paramedic or no role really that exists yet.
And I think New Mexico would be a great state for something like that given our environment
and some of the places where paramedics work can be very far away from resources and having
expanded skills and expanded abilities to manage patients out of the hospital without
maybe transporting them to the hospital I think would be really great for the state.
But we'll see in the future.
Yeah.
Whatever we could do in the field to keep people out of the hospital would be advantageous.
But that's still not quite happening here yet.
It is.
But I was surprised to learn like we have EMT basics that do sutures here out in the
field and some of the rural like Pueblos.
There's basics that are trained to do sutures.
And so I was really surprised coming here.
That was sort of a big difference where just depending on where you are, there may be
opportunities for that.
But we'll see if it grows.
I think with the way our state's EMS education is, I think it's a good state that could potentially
have something like that.
For sure.
Yeah.
I remember when I did my EMT, my basic in Virginia years ago, I could give four drugs
and one of them was oxygen.
Yeah.
And like a basic here in New Mexico, I don't remember how many they can give, but it's
a bunch.
It's a lot.
Yeah.
And like an intermediate can give TXA.
They can manage a patient on like numerous medications for an IFT, which in a lot of
states, paramedics aren't even allowed to manage.
So there is some things about working here that make it pretty unique.
For sure.
And we got the best landscapes.
Yes, the best landscapes, definitely.
And yeah, the best green chili.
Well, here at the community college, you guys last year started a critical care review course
or a critical care transport review course.
Yeah.
You want to talk about that a bit?
Sure.
So the design or the idea came from, like we talked about, there's a lot of paramedics
here can transport a lot of pretty sick patients, basically right out of school.
And locally, our fire department was getting asked to transport patients on impellas and
numerous trips and pediatric patients on high flow and things that typically more classically,
like in an urban environment, like a critical care transport team or flight team would handle
those types of transports.
And so we definitely saw a need to increase the level of training, but there was literally
no options other than take like an impact EMS course or flight bridge ed course, which
are great for test prep, but to really get hands on with an impeller device or managing
vent vented patients or multiple drips and what the logistics looks like.
We wanted to create a course where not just paramedics, but other providers as well could
come and get hands on training in that space.
And so the course is designed to be a full college credit critical care course that can
be used as a review course, but also to take someone from no critical care background to
being able to do the job.
And right now it's a semester long program.
It's a little tight for one semester to get all of the things covered that we want to
cover, but it prepares, you know, paramedics to take the FPC or CCP, a nurse could potentially
take the CFRN after this course.
We have respiratory therapists that are interested.
We have physician assistants that are interested in the course.
And it really just covers, you know, all of the things that you might find on a critical
care exam, but also a lot of the hands on kind of minutia of like moving a drip over
or setting up events and just zeroing an art line.
And how does that, how do you hook it up to your monitor?
All the things you don't really learn in a prep class.
And also we go into depth in some other topics as well as like ultrasound and things like
that.
And we've added this year now clinical rotations for the critical care class as well.
So they'll go to the ICU, they'll shadow a respiratory therapist as well on the ICU,
and then they'll do some rotations with sonography.
Awesome.
So, and you guys have like a pretty unique space here that you have a SIM lab set up
with both like a bedside set up where you can like work through a scenario where a
patient is lying on a hospital bed with a monitor on the machines attached.
And you also have like a back of an ambulance so you can simulate actually having to move
your patient while you're managing all these things.
Yeah.
Which I think is like one of the challenges for people who are new to this space.
Totally.
And that like for me being when I was a new flight paramedic, like, okay, what do you
hand up the tunnel first and the aircraft is at the pumps, do I hand the oxygen connection
for the vents, you know, and it's like, Oh, now this is wrapped around their leg, and
this is on the seatbelt.
So there's all these like little nuance things to making your life easier.
And so yeah, we try to simulate or create that environment.
So we have them go from the like a simulated ICU, move on to a gurney and then move into
an ambulance and they have to keep all of the equipment working and we don't let them
verbalize anything where they can be like, I'm just going to verbalize that I'm hooking
the vent up.
It's like, no, I actually hooked that because that's part of that logistics that makes that
move challenging.
So they get that experience.
And so when they come out, they're a little bit more prepared than like your typical,
you know, paramedic or nurse who maybe he's never done that kind of thing before.
Yeah, that's awesome.
I think that's definitely a gap in most the offerings that are out there.
Yeah, for sure.
It's really like that's all on the job learning a lot of the time and you know, which totally
which is good.
But I think it's good to show up a little bit, understand, you know, what the challenges
are for sure.
Yeah.
And I imagine the expectation is not that people go from your prep class to being able
to like competently perform like the flight role, but it's more to give them like some
exposure to that and get them familiar with the process.
They know what they're getting into.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You know, we're expecting them to walk out and function exactly as a flight crew member
should but it gives them I think a pretty good foundation, you know, and we're tweaking
it.
It's a new class.
So it's going to take some time to really get it to how we want it to be.
But I think it's it's going pretty well.
So right on.
And for folks that are here in New Mexico, when is the next class and is there space
or how does that work if someone is interested in participating?
So right now the next class is going to be over the summer semester.
So it'll be a bit accelerated.
That class is open.
Registration doesn't open until April.
So there's still a little bit of time to get your interest in.
Basically, people can reach out to me.
They can go on our website, sfcc.edu and find the paramedicine page.
And on there, there's a little application for the critical care program.
They just fill that out and they need to apply to the college.
They need to be licensed somewhere.
And either as a nurse, respiratory therapist, paramedic, PA, whoever is interested, they
just need to be licensed at that level or above.
And then, yeah, we'll get you in the class.
Right on.
Yeah, it's awesome.
I don't know of anyone else who's like regularly doing critical care transport classes like
in person in the state.
Yeah, there had been historically some in the state in the past down in Roswell.
I think there used to be one in Santa Fe many years ago.
But what's unique about this class is you get college degree credit for it.
It's transferable.
It's something you can take with you on your transcripts.
So it's not just like a hey pay us 400 bucks and we'll give you a cert.
So it gives you something that is a little bit more academic.
And yeah, it is a space in that is lacking, I think, for sure.
If you look, especially in the western United States, there's like very few, if any, critical
care programs through colleges.
But it's required to do that.
Any job in that space, you need to have that certification.
And the only way to get it is to take an online class or study yourself or through
an agency or something like that.
Yeah.
So if you're going to pay to prep for the test anyways, because you want that flight
job, might as well take a class that shows you how to do the hands on parts of it as
well.
Yeah.
And if you like to learn in person and maybe go a little more in depth and spend a little
more time on each one of those topics and then that hands on piece really, I think,
is huge that you don't get in that online class.
Yeah.
And if there's folks who have experience in that space and do some teaching, are you still
looking for folks to help on the carrying out the class side of things on the teaching
side?
Yeah, definitely.
So critical care, we have openings like yourself work for us as a skills instructor or an adjunct
and that really, we really need people in the critical care space that are interested
to come in and help with that.
As the class grows, we found that doing these extended simulations can be pretty involved
and take hours.
And so patient, you know, students, we want every student to get through each SIM.
So we would like to have more instructors.
We have a pretty good pool of critical care folks.
We have two PAs that work for us.
We have one PA, special forces medic that just was hired.
We have a couple flight medics from various agencies around.
We have yourself.
So we have a pretty good cadre of folks, but always having people to help run these simulations
to make sure all the students are getting that hands on is key.
Yeah, that makes sense.
So that's the critical care class that you're doing, but you also do EMT and medic classes
here as well.
Yeah, we do.
So everything from technically EMR all the way up to critical care.
So we offer basic EMT classes or EMT pretty much every semester.
We do advanced EMT and we have a paramedic program that goes, starts every year.
We start a new cohort.
And these all have the option to do for college credit as well?
Yes, our paramedic program, they all are college credit.
So everything is towards a degree.
And so people can come in with no EMS background and pursue our paramedicine degree.
So they will start in EMT, they'll take biology, they'll take a couple of their gen ed classes
and then apply to the paramedic program once they get their EMT.
And then they can graduate with their associates degree by the end of the paramedic program.
So our paramedic program is not obviously in the US, we don't require a degree, but
we are moving towards not a degree requirement per se, but we've made our degree program
for our paramedics very streamlined so that they can earn that associates degree by the
time they graduate.
And I would say like majority of our students now pursue that degree.
It's where before when it was like, okay, you had three extra semesters onto your already
four semester long paramedic program.
A lot of people waited to get that degree, maybe waited till later, but we've changed
that degree plan a bit.
So someone could come in with no college credit, take the gen ed, maybe some of their gen
ed their first semester and then finish a couple of online classes during the program
and graduate with the degree.
So that's been a big goal.
That's awesome.
And I've been out of that space for a while, but I imagine it's fairly different than how
most paramedic programs across the country are doing it these days.
Yeah.
The difference, the disparity between paramedic programs is pretty vast in the US.
It's like, so since 2013, every paramedic program in the country has to be what's called
K-HEP accredited.
And that started because it, K-HEP has been around.
Paramedic programs have been accredited for a very long time, but it wasn't a requirement.
And in 2013, the national registry said, if you're going to take the national exam, you
had to have gone to a K-HEP accredited program.
So that pretty much sealed the deal.
Now all 50 states utilize the national registry.
So every paramedic program for the most part, unless there's some states that still recognize
a state paramedic, all have a K-HEP accreditation.
And so part of that is like, if you are going to a paramedic school, you have to be awarded
college credit by an institution.
Doesn't necessarily have to be by the paramedic program, but the program itself has to be
sponsored by an institution that would give college credit for that.
And it has to be towards degree completion.
It couldn't just be like, we're going to give you 50 credit hours of whatever elective
and welding or I don't know, it has to be towards degree completion of something.
And so pretty much now every paramedic program, every paramedic student has the option to
get a degree, at least an associates degree.
It's just how we get there in terms of making that a requirement is a different, a little
bit different of a discussion.
But I think our model is pretty good because a student can come in and not spend much extra
time in school and get that college degree and really open up a lot more doors, give
themselves a lot more bigger jumping board, so to speak, to go to different things and
expand their career.
And I think New Mexico does a good job because we are like, we have six paramedic programs
and they all offer a degree and one of them is a four year degree.
So I think we're pretty unique in that aspect.
Do you know offhand how, like what percentage of your students who finish the paramedic
portion get a degree?
I don't know the exact percentage, but I know since we've updated our degree plan like this
current cohort, I think everybody in this cohort is pursuing that degree.
So that has been a big, big, big benefit for us to see that growth where before it
was probably in the 30% because it was such an extra add on of time.
And if you're trying to get out and work and you don't want to invest that extra time,
I do understand it's kind of, you know, it's not typical to spend seven semesters in school
to get a, an associates degree.
And our paramedic students were, when we calculated it compared to a nursing degree had somewhere
in the ballpark of 75 to 85 credit hours in a nursing degree, it was like 69 credit
hours and they're spending about the same amount of time in school.
So we really wanted to make sure we were like better accounting for those, those hours.
Right on.
Yeah.
And you mentioned that all the paramedic programs in the state now, all of them offer
like a similar pathway.
Yep.
Is there anything specific in like how things are done here in New Mexico or like the challenges
to EMS education that are specific to our state that you guys are trying to work on
at the moment?
There are, the state has a lot of challenges in healthcare in general, recruiting providers.
And so we, we have shortages just like every other, every other field, but the paramedic
shortages is pretty profound.
We just did a big survey across every survey, every survey across every service in New Mexico,
fire service, third service, hospital, private flight services.
And a lot of different areas in our state are pretty understaffed when it comes to paramedics.
And that's true across the country.
And I think when you look at that, people start saying, well, what are the, where are
those challenges coming from?
And the, an easy solution is to be like, well, the school's too hard.
The school's too long.
They have to take this validated national exam and it's challenging and some people
don't pass it.
And some of those things are looked at as like barriers to fixing staffing problems.
And so I think every paramedic program faces like some of those where they're like trying
to stand up to this idea that education is causing staffing problems.
I'm not saying that that's the sentiment here in this state, but we definitely face staffing
issues and staffing shortages.
And there's a lot of discussions about how we should go about fixing that.
And I think one of the ways we want to fix that is not, is by recruiting students into
our program and by not necessarily by increasing our standards by, and that may be counterintuitive,
but we want to be the program that's looked at as, you know, that's going to, where students
can come and learn more, do expanded clinicals.
Like, you know, our students get a lot of clinicals that are above and beyond what a
typical paramedic does.
I mean, they're certified in ultrasound.
When they graduate, they do multiple rotations with sonographers and doing ultrasounds in
the ER.
So they're pretty expert in like leading kind of technologies in the EMS world.
And that's what we want to utilize to like draw people into the profession of like, look,
there is these great clinical opportunities and this is a really rewarding job instead
of, all right, we're going to just teach you the bare bones and get you through a program
in six state, nine months and get you out in the field and then you'll quit two years
later.
So we want to make people interested in becoming paramedics.
And we also want to make sure that we are trying to take in as many students as we can.
So that's a huge challenge.
Like are there enough clinical sites?
Are there enough internships for patients or students to go to?
So that's something we run into.
We only historically have accepted only 15 students into each cohort and we're trying
to up that number so that we can help alleviate some of these shortages.
Yeah.
And you mentioned that you guys are including ultrasound training in your initial paramedic
courses.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's cool.
And we've also seen, you and I were just talking about this, a lot of the ground services
in our area are starting to introduce that as well.
Whereas traditionally it's been something that more senior providers removed from school,
like take that on.
Yeah, I think so.
I've seen the utility of ultrasound in my own practice and I was not one of these people
that was like super bought into it initially.
But after seeing in a variety of different realms, I mean, from working in a critical
care transport world and helping guide treatment decisions to working at ski patrol and detecting
a tension pneumothorax after a tree strike.
I've seen this tool that's quite simple actually to teach somebody some basic skills and really
make a big difference in practice.
And so we wanted to bring that into the paramedic world and kind of model a little bit more
how like a physician would be trained in medical school to use ultrasound and it's to incorporate
it into their assessment and to utilize those findings just as like more evidence.
And we also use it to teach the anatomy and physiology.
So they start during their anatomy and physiology, which is their entire first semester.
They're identifying like gallbladder, liver, kidney, renal pyramids, different vessels,
aorta, IVC, hepatic vessels, structures in the lung.
They look at heart valves, they're labeling all these things in their final, in A&P, their
lab final is to like, they have a list of structures and they have to find it with ultrasound
and label it.
So that's kind of how we introduce it.
We don't really teach any findings.
We're just learning how to find stuff and point it out.
And then each block we introduce things.
So like in respiratory, they learn all the basic assessments that a paramedic student
needs to learn, but then they're going to learn, you know, to look for lung sliding,
what a consolidation looks like, what B lines look like, what a pleural effusion looks like
and how that would present.
And then in cardiology, we teach them how to look for estimate ejection fraction and
look for like signs of infarct or ventricular strain or mitral regurgitation and as well
as like aortic assessment and IVC assessment.
They start incorporating this into scenarios and then in their medical block, they kind
of learn more like the rush, how to differentiate hypotension and trauma.
Obviously we teach them the fast and then this all kind of culminates and then they
go to clinicals and they get to actually do these on patients and then they spend time
with a sonographer.
So it's pretty robust.
I mean, it's like, it's, it's a over 15 months.
They get quite a bit of hours.
Yeah.
So throughout the entire course, they're developing the skillset, which I think is awesome.
And I think really that's how it needs to be.
I think this, like, I've seen a lot of rollouts of ultrasound and agencies where they do like
a 30 minute training and then it just sits in the ambulance and never gets used because
everyone's like, I don't know that training.
I didn't really feel super comfortable.
For sure.
Like, I don't even know if I can find the structure I'm looking for.
How do I even turn it on?
Yeah.
Like, so yeah.
And if you don't have confidence in like what you're doing, like to look for something or
what you're looking at, you're probably not going to adopt that into your practice.
So we wanted to, essentially the goal is these people can go out and train and like behind
you is one of our students from the Apache Nation, last cohort, he put together this
whole research project on how to train every, all the medics up in the Hickory Apache Nation
to use ultrasound.
And it's something now they're incorporating and it's a great tool for them because they're
sometimes four hours from the nearest resource.
So they can really get a lot more information.
So yeah, it's been pretty cool to see.
Yeah, it's awesome.
Yeah.
Do you know of any other programs, any other medic programs that are doing something similar
in their initial training?
I don't know if anybody's fully gone in as much as we have into it, but I know there
are a lot of programs that definitely have ultrasounds and maybe incorporate it into
some extent into their programs.
I know like EKU utilizes it.
I think Oklahoma City or one of the programs out there is utilizing it, but I think in
terms of really incorporating it into different aspects of the program, we've gone pretty
full in on that.
Yeah, that seems like it.
And then maybe not to this extreme, but is there anything else that you're trying to
do in your EMS education stuff here at Santa Fe Community College that you think is different
than how most folks are doing it?
Yeah, I mean, it's just, I think we don't treat people like paramedics, right?
You're going to be an advanced clinician of some kind.
And that's sort of how I look at it.
It's this idea of like, we're training you to be just working this emergency medical
transport mindset.
But we kind of are training people to be just give them a broader idea of being a healthcare
practitioner, so to speak, and a better idea of the healthcare system and how to navigate
different aspects of the healthcare system to have a deeper understanding of what is
going to happen with their patient further down the line in their care.
So there's an expectation of like our paramedic students to understand lab values, to understand
blood gases, to understand all the different classes of home medications when we're talking
about antihypertensives.
And is this a L type or non L type calcium channel blocker?
And to understand what all that stuff means.
And I think some paramedics out there are like, oh, that's stupid.
I don't need to know that stuff.
But for us, it's kind of looking at, well, that's what being a healthcare provider is
about.
It's like, there are things as a nurse that you had to learn that you're like, well, I
don't ever really utilize that in my practice, but it's about having knowledge, right?
And I think so our paramedic students, we want them to be, to regard themselves as clinicians
and not just someone that takes someone to the hospital.
So that's something I think that we do is different.
We incorporate things like vent management.
They learn pretty in depth by pap, they learn high flow, our respiratory therapy director
comes over and does lectures with them on vent management and things like that.
They learn what else they have blood products, like simulated, we have a blood cooler, they
have plasma and whole blood simulated.
We have blood warmers.
They learn more advanced procedures like the finger thoracostomies and kind of the latest
research in everything is sort of where we want to be and where we want them to be.
So that's awesome.
Yeah.
And it's cool to see.
It's fun.
It's a lot of fun to do it.
And I don't, it's mostly just, you know, I think getting this job was like, cool.
Now I can like make the paramedic program.
I always wanted to see exist.
That's kind of cool.
Yeah.
It's been really cool.
And I have a great group to like, I have two full time people who are just incredibly supportive
and helpful.
And then a lot of part time folks to that buy into this mission and want to come and
participate and you know, and that's been pretty great to have that help.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Cool.
I think the last thing I just wanted to mention is that, uh, Joe and I have been talking about,
uh, offering CEU hours for some of the stuff that we're doing at Riker medical.
So hopefully in the near future, you'll be able to get CEU through Santa Fe community
college for some of our podcasts that are focused on more clinical subjects.
Also for some of the review stuff we're doing, particularly like the event management book,
we have questions that are in the works for every chapter that goes with it.
Um, so yeah, definitely.
Yeah.
I really appreciate you helping out with that.
And that'll be cool when that's finalized.
I'm super excited.
I think the podcast delivery of medical education is, has been such a huge like benefit to all,
whether you're a nurse, paramedic, I think being able to, you know, listen to like the
okay medic or whoever else and pick up little clinical tidbits has been huge.
And so if we can participate in that in some way, I think that's awesome.
For sure.
Cool.
Anything else you wanted to mention?
Anything I didn't ask about?
I don't know.
If you want to come to paramedic school applications are open.
So yeah.
And we'll make sure we get links for everything on the notes.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Now our thanks for having me.
Thanks for chatting.
Thanks for coming on.
Yeah.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
But real quick, before we get going, just a couple of shout outs.
First is to the St. Fisher church of evidence based medicine.
If you haven't seen their page, definitely go check it out.
We used to also give a shout out to the pragmatic paramedics.
I don't think they're active anymore, but definitely take a look at their back episodes.
It's a good podcast.
And then lastly, shout out to my friend, Josh Pittman and his friend, Kevin Pons.
They're the ones who put the music together.